He created a body that was to become the gold standard for muscular development.
He would use it to achieve one goal after another,
rising to the very pinnacle of not one,
but three careers from the very start.
Arnold Schwarzenegger had the odds stacked against him.
He was dismissed.
He was ridiculed.
He was parodied.
All massive.
Leslie,
what people fail to realize was that Arnold strongest muscle,
there wasn't as biceps.
It was his brain with its.
He orchestrated career moves that took him to the very,
very top.
In this biographics video,
we're going to uncover the unlikely rags to riches story of the one and only
Arnold Schwartzenegger.
Oh,
notes Watson scenango was born in the tiny and Austrian village of near Grand
Central and the 30th,
1947.
His father,
Gustavo,
was the local police chief arnold and his older brother Meinhart grub under the
tough discipline of a man who was used to being a bait on those early years.
They were incredibly regimented.
It'd be up at six and then off to get the milk from the farm next door.
Then you would have to do a set of physical exercises that his father had
written out for him.
He would earn his breakfast if I'm doing a certain number of setups.
In the afternoon after I'd finished his homework and chores,
his father made arnold in mine heart practice soccer.
No matter how bad the weather was,
if they messed up on a play,
they got yelled at because staff had been a champion Ice Keller in his younger
years and he pushed his sons.
Do you excel physically with his father's pushing?
I'll load first.
Got into competitive sports at the age of 10.
He played soccer passionately for almost five years.
When he was 15,
I was a soccer coach.
Decided that lifting weights for an hour once a week would be a good way for his
players to stay in shape.
Sorry.
He took them for a visit to the local gym.
This is a day if it would absolutely change Arnold's life.
He was mesmerized by the sheer size of the bodybuilders you've talked to the
gym,
waging war with steel weights on older with leisure.
Record his feelings and his 19,
77 or so biography arnold,
the education of a bodybuilder there.
It was before me,
my life,
the answer had been seeking.
It clicked.
It was something I suddenly just seemed to reach out and find as if I'd been
crossing a suspended bridge and finally stepped off onto solid grounds on old.
He embraced weightlifting.
He seemed discovered that he had an amazing ability to build muscle and within
two years he had already overtaken most of the other trainers at the gym and
grabbed swear.
He worked out religiously.
He also trained harder than anyone else.
One Sunday discovering that the gym was closed,
he actually smashed the window in order to get in so that he could complete his
work out his father,
that he was less than impressed with his son's new found obsession.
Bodybuilding,
it was really a fringe sport in Australia at that time with those who are
politic of what's being looked down upon and considered in some way defective.
When it was discovered that Donald had pictures of half naked men with bulging
muscles on his bedroom wall,
a psychiatrist was called in to save on old from himself.
The psychologist assured his parents that this was simply a phase and arnold
would absolutely grow out of this and well,
as you probably know,
he absolutely didn't.
By the age of 17,
Arnold had already realized that bodybuilding was going to be his vehicle to
weld wide fame.
He spends many Saturday afternoons down at the local movie theater,
watching bodybuilders turned,
actors such as Steve Reeves,
centers,
personal favorite ranch park.
He watched them onscreen Blang,
Hercules,
and other mythic heroes.
They had used bodybuilding in order to create careers as movie stars,
and that was exactly what Arnold wanted to do.
Only he was going to be bigger and better than any of them.
Arnold,
he entered the Austrian army in 1965 in order to fulfill his one year of
service.
By now,
it builds his body to 200 pounds of Herculean muscle.
He was assigned as a drive it in a tank units.
Shortly after he was inducted,
Arnold received an invitation to compete in the junior division of the midst of
Europe contest in Stuttgart,
Germany,
but he was in the middle of basic training.
No soldier was allowed to leave the base for any reason,
but almost knew that his destiny was tied with winning this contest,
so he decided to go,
Hey,
well they in order to get beat,
he crawled over the wall,
taking only the clothes he was wearing and barely enough money to buy a third
class ticket to Germany.
When he arrived at the competition,
he actually had to borrow someone else's posing trunks and they're tanning oil
still.
His muscles were undeniable.
Last night it was announced junior Mr Europe.
At first the army,
they were not exactly impressed and he was actually jailed for seven days with
only a blanket on a cold stone bench and almost no food,
but within a few days the news of his victory,
it spreads as the top brass decided that the title added Prestige to the army.
When he returned to the ranks,
he was held up as a sort of ideal with his drill instructor.
Telling the troops,
you have to fight for your father,
that you have to take courage.
Look at what Schwartz negatives.
Just to win this title,
not following his stint in the army.
Arnold took a job as a gym instructor at a Health Club in Munich,
Germany.
This presented him with the ideal opportunity to train for the 19,
66 Mrs Europe competition.
This was the next step and his master plan to become the best built man on the
planet.
He trained twice a day,
working like a champ possessed in order to forge his winning physique.
By the time he arrived in stuck out for the contest,
people were anxious to get a look at this monster from Munich,
the one that that had room is all about all of the attention infused on old with
a great deal of confidence under your already felt like the winner.
Arnold's,
when that day was so emphatic that the judge has offered to pay his way to the
upcoming Mr. Universe.
He arrived in London,
I mean almost no English,
but as soon as he stepped out of his cap,
people began mobbing him.
They'd all been waiting for them,
the first bodybuilder in Europe with 20 inch arms,
but unfortunately he didn't win that day.
The American shatter.
Your son had a more complete defined physique and he forced Donald's to accept
second place on.
Ols returned to Munich and threw himself back into his training.
He shut everything out of his mind and concentrated on only one thing.
Winning the 19,
67 Mr. universe competition and sure enough on September the 23rd,
19,
67 Arnold Schwarzenegger became,
that's 20 years of age.
The youngest Mr University history a year later and even more massive on
returning to London to claim the professional Mr. Universe title,
following that victory,
Donald received the phone call that would prove to be the next great signposts
to his future on the other end of the line and it was Joe Weider Bodybuilding
Guru and publisher of Muscle Builder magazine,
wider invited Arnold to compete in the IFB be Mr. Universe in Miami and then
come to train in California and work for him
on older arrives in America in September 1968 with the gym bag at 20 US dollars.
Still virtually no English,
he settled into a small apartment in Venice beach and was given a small stipend
money wider in exchange for the rights to use this image in magazines.
Arnold's plan was to stay in the USA for one year,
absorb their trading strategies,
and then use them to beat the Americans at their own game.
Almost began training.
It's a small gym in Venice Beach,
Los Angeles called Gold's gym.
He rubbed shoulders with all the American top.
Bodybuilders quickly established himself as the leader of the pack.
In 1970 arnold,
he won the coveted triple crown of bodybuilding claiming at the Mr Universe,
Mr. World,
ams,
the Mr Olympia titles.
He was now the undisputed king of bodybuilding.
Arnold went onto win six consecutive Mr Olympia titles as he completely
dominated the sport and with this well,
he was ready to implement phase two if it's master
flat
in services,
Jay y dot.
I got a call from a film production company looking for a bodybuilder to play
Hercules in a low budget film.
Why did he immediately thought of Arnold's telling the producer that Arnie had
been a shakespearian actor,
that back in Europe,
they signed him up immediately.
The result was Hercules goes to New York and it was to be Arnold first stands,
most forgettable film.
It's credits.
Reid,
Arnold strong and thick Austrian accent was actually dubbed over.
Still.
They got paid $10,000,
which he invested into California real estate his next paycheck or is it
actually takes some time coming because bottled found Hollywood's less receptive
than he had hoped,
several agents and tells him that he had everything going against him.
He a long name,
which was difficult to pronounce,
to strain Jackson's salvador loft and unusual builds which will never make it
into films for Ronald's.
This was the very motivation that he needed back in Australia.
He had been told that he could never become a champion bodybuilder,
and yet that is exactly what he became.
Now,
he would reinvents himself through the same as sheer hard work and dedication
that he had learned in the gym in order to become the highest paid movie star on
the planet.
He would make those agents in their words on north.
He began acting lessons in 1974.
He won a supporting role in the Bob Rafelson movie.
Stay hungry.
In this movie,
he played a bodybuilder named Joe Sando,
so it's hardly stretched his acting ability still.
He was absolutely determined to make an impression and make an impression.
He did.
He won the Golden Globe for best newcomer.
Then in 1977,
the documentary pumping on opened in theaters the chronicle Donald's victory in
the 1975 Mr Olympia over the new for the future incredible hulk as his charming,
confident self Arnold's onscreen charisma.
It was impossible to resist pumping on lead just more roles in the movie.
It's the villain and the Jayne Mansfield Story.
Bali.
This point in his life,
I know he was already a successful businessman.
He was combining real estate investments of best selling biography and
bodybuilding training courses.
This meant that he could afford to wait for just the right film projects.
He filled his time with public appearances and social functions.
One such function was the Robert F Kennedy tennis tournament in Hyannisport.
There he caught the eye of a beautiful,
dark haired girl by the name of Maria Shriver,
that she was the daughter of gardens and Eunice Kennedy Shriver and the niece of
John Fitzgerald,
Kennedy Animals and Maria.
Well,
they fell in love at first sight,
the Shriver's.
They were great philanthropists and through them monitored was introduced to
these Special Olympics,
which she has been passionately involved with ever since.
In 1979,
I began a career as a CBS sports commentator.
He also graduated from the University of Wisconsin with a business degree,
but it was a year later.
He's stunned the bodybuilding world with his comeback at the Mr Olympia
competition in Australia.
There he captured his seventh title,
cementing his legendary status as the greatest bodybuilder of all time.
Arnold's come back though it wasn't without controversy.
He went to Australia in the role of a TV reporter only signing his name to the
register at the last minute.
He was also good friends with the head judge bodybuilding legend build Po.
The general consensus was the Donald on stage.
It was a mere shadow of his former self is victory,
was for the first time actually greeted by Booz still.
He had his seventh Mr Olympia title,
the great shape that Arnold said goes into for the 1980 Mr Libya propelled him
to his breakthrough role as Conan the barbarian.
After spending a year in working on his speech and learning how to use our
broadsoft's,
he headed off to Yugoslavia in Spain for a grueling six month shoot Conan the
barbarian.
It rakes in more than a hundred million dollars at the box office together with
its sequel Conan the destroyer,
it firmly embedded the name Arnold Schwartzenegger into movie go is
consciousness.
As following his success with the Conan movies,
Arnold was offered a low budget movie by first time director and screenwriter,
James Cameron.
This would prove to be his most iconic role in the terminator on old place,
a sidebar except back in time to kill the mother of the man who will save
humankind from destruction.
The role well,
it was made for Ronald's,
his accent and his body.
The very things that agents had said would work against him were perfect for the
part of the thousands.
The terminator was an absolute smash,
firmly establishing Arnold as the next great action stop.
By 1985.
He had already been named international star of the year and on April the 26th,
19,
86,
arnold's a staunch Republican as Maria Shriver,
a member of democratic royalty,
or they were married but their honeymoon.
It was barely over before arnold flew to Mexico to film his latest action
blockbuster credit at this movie again,
one in the title action star of the year after a string of action films come
onto a raw deal,
predecessor and the running man.
The forward thinking arnold was ready for a new challenge and that challenge is
comedy.
So unsurprisingly,
very few are willing to take a gamble on Arnold as a comic actor,
but one who was was the director Ivan Reitman.
You created a special vehicle for adults this vehicle,
but it was called twins.
The irresistible chemistry of Schwarzenegger and Danny Devito made twins and
immediate hit,
and two years later,
honnold again teamed up with and for kindergarten cop,
another comedy success.
A large part of the success of these films is Arnold's ability to laugh at
himself on always,
always got the job,
which was really endearing to fans over and above that I know it's also a gifted
comedian.
As anyone who's seen pumping iron will know now,
one person who noticed on those abilities on kindergarten cop,
especially his rapport with children with President George Bush,
Bush appointed as the chairman of the President's Council on physical fitness.
Now this could have really been a symbolic role,
but arnold,
he totally threw himself into it with absolute relish visiting every state in
order to promote the fitness lifestyle.
Now,
this movie winning streak,
it totally continued for Arnold yet total recall and terminator two,
this sequel cost $100,
million dollars,
making it the most expensive film at the time it returns an astonishing 519
point $8,000,000 with Arnie.
Pocketing a cruel 15 million.
Now,
Arnold's next big movie out seeing was the last action hero,
a $100,000,000 extravaganza,
which seemed like a short thing,
but felt it was a box office bomb and critical flop.
Hollywood's was really quick to tear it down,
claiming that his time in the limelight was over,
but Schwartzenegger,
he had other ideas.
He bounced back from defeat with the same focus determination as in as
bodybuilding days.
He retained with James Cameron for the action packs.
James Bond Spoof true lies well.
The movie was a smash on nodes.
Critics were once again silenced and he was back on top.
In the mid 19 nineties,
all began focusing on giving Max to the country that had given him so much.
He became an organizer and sponsor of the annual inner city games.
He was also very involved in the afterschool care program.
In 2003 during an appearance on the Jay Leno show,
Arnold announced his candidacy for governor of California.
This was following the recall of Governor Gray Davis sparks by the California
electricity crisis.
I'd he ran an energetic campaign discipline.
It's a smear campaign organized by the La Times and number of women claims over
the years on altered,
molested them while of claims to have had a fence with him still on old.
He was able to rise above this with his unique mix of chogm intelligence,
and on one occasion someone threw an egg which splashes Omanis jackets.
He immediately went to the Jack is all,
threw it over his shoulder and called out.
Hey,
I a bacon with those eggs on he,
he easily won the governorship.
Hands immediately sat about cleaning house at Sacramento,
bringing his own unique styles.
That position such as calling as democratic opposition,
gunny men almost first time it was marked by such early victories as repealing a
vehicle license in Greece and stopping illegals from getting driver's licenses,
but then powerful state to unions began to oppose his initiatives and for ballot
measures.
He sponsored in a special election in 2005.
They were the fetus.
Despite this,
he was reelected governor in 2006 with 56 percent of the votes on a second time.
He put a lot of effort into environmental issues.
In 2006,
he signs the global warming Solutions Act,
making California the first state to put a cap on greenhouse gas emissions on
old second time as governor.
It came to an end in January of 2011.
A few months later,
the La Times ran a cover story repurposing that Arnold had fathered a child 14
years previously that the family's longterm mate as a direct result of this
revelation and Maria and just that 25 year marriage,
she and therefore children moved out to the family home in Brentwood.
Okay.
Arnold's post governorship movie career has seen him feature in such action as
the expendables two and three escape plan,
sabotage,
and the fifth installment Terminator in which he battles his younger self on lts
maintained strong ties to the bodybuilding world following his retirement from
the sport.
In 1975,
he promoted the Mr Olympia competition.
Then in 1989,
he ends longtime partner Jim lorimer started the Arnold Schwarzenegger classic,
which is now the second biggest pro bodybuilding show just behind Mr Olympia
Arnold credits all of his success.
Do these self discipline drive and focus that he learns from his body building
career in more recent times,
Donald has been involved in a social media feud with President Donald trump in
the wake of ani,
replacing trump won celebrity apprentice.
Trump blames on all for the show.
That's dismal ratings,
and Donald offered the commander in chief some timely advice on how to run the
country on old,
a staunch Republican,
refuse to vote for trump and the 2016 presidential election the first time he
had not supported the Republican candidate since becoming a US citizen.
Although it's about all we would all love to see unfortunately on challenge the
Donald for the top job as he wasn't born in the United States,
even though he did become a citizen in 1983 on.
Well today,
he still lives the fitness lifestyle.
He just celebrated his 70th birthday
kind of.
All
right,
let's turn it around to the back.
It still works out every day,
so I really hope you found the video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos just like this every Monday and Thursday.
Also check out some of the other videos that are over there on the right and as
always I'll see you in the next one.
Okay.